a one-room apartment in Northeast Mumbai
Chaya Gaikwad lives here with her large
family Chaya dropped out of school when
she was 10 she cooked and fleet
informally in different Mumbai homes for
decades the work was back working the
jobs in regular and I had a hard time my
previous employers is to yell at me they
would threaten to fire me if I didn't
show up in time if I didn't do the tasks
fast enough I was constantly worried
that changed a year ago when Chaya
joined my didi calm a mobile application
that connects cleaning staff with
households in Mumbai Chaya now enters
new recruits in housekeeping the maids
receive a fixed salary that gets paid
into the bank accounts conditions that
are unheard of among India's domestic
servants it's an industry that's highly
informal and unorganized Chaya takes
home nearly twelve thousand rupees or
one hundred and sixty two euros a month
nearly 60 percent more than a previous
income employees also given a smartphone
and trained in using the app founder
Johnny cha grew up with household health
like most urban Indians with many maids
they hired being illiterate or
semi-literate he says his developers
struggled to make the app user-friendly
when they see someone coming in a
uniform with the smartphone jacket
the difference the perception that
creates in the - very specific job and
not someone who's living in a slum next
before trial heads off to a new
assignment
she works in about four to five homes
every day for an hour each the company
organizes transport to ferry maids to
their workplace Preeti oak turned to my
VD after her regular maid abruptly
stopped coming leaving her in the lurch
she initially had reservations about
quality and service and whether she
could trust a complete stranger in a
home but not any more food no hassles
and then nothing and we would replace
supposing one made his sake or anything
they would send another maid so no
hassle actually it was quite relaxing I
would say I would just tell her what to
do and then we would do over for Chaya
joining to my didi platform has
certainly paid off but the biggest
change she says is how she is now
treated in a society notorious for
condescending attitudes towards
household help mala galya galya dear
madam if my customers actually greet me
first and say namaste didi how are you
I'm overwhelmed I'm not used to it they
tell me you're a human being - now they
treat me like a family member
thanks to technology
India's invisible domestic workforce is
embracing modernity and living a more
dignified life